okay
to people who are joining this this is a
slightly different kind of discussion we
are talking about recording in progress
direction
something that i consider to be a major
direction in terms of language design
and we have a whole bunch of people here
who i hope
can
uh
contribute in one way or another to the
things that we're thinking about
so i just posted this post
um
yesterday about
what i've been calling multi-computation
and
here's the basic idea
the
um
as it's relevant to
our language design
what we mostly do
in you know how does how does wolfman
language fundamentally work well it's
making transformations for expressions
based on patterns
and
what we're doing is our evaluator takes
the you know the first instance
that matches uses that and keeps
iterating until you reach a fixed point
clearly
that approach
so most of the time it's sufficient to
just know
you know
we're just interested in what the answer
is
okay the whole idea of multi-computation
is this notion that there are multiple
uh in in principle any given computation
there are multiple things that can be
done in that computation
and that we can therefore that and that
even knowing the
you know knowing what the answer is is
non-trivial now i think this model of
computation this idea that there are
many paths to follow is something that
implicitly is used in many different
areas for example
it's used even in it's used in even in
the evaluation of most recursive
functions like a fibonacci or something
like that you're following multiple
paths and in that case you're
aggregating all of the leaves or another
thing you might be doing is doing a
search problem where you say i just want
one answer and you want to find one leaf
that satisfies some properties
or you might be doing theorem proving
where you want to find one path that
corresponds to a proof
or you might want to do any of the kinds
of things that sort of logic programming
uh brought to one
one of the points of this
uh
this post is making the point that there
are a bunch of models that one can
imagine making that are sort of inspired
by a physics project
that
um for which
the uh
the question of what the answer is is
something essentially determined by an
observer an observer who is somehow for
example making
reference frames
what is a reference frame it's something
which defines equivalence classes of
things here so we might say
this you know someplace up here we had
some pictures of kind of reference
frames in which we said that for example
the simultaneous elements at this time
step will be considered to be these or
whatever else
and so
in a sense we're we're taking this
multi-way collection of this sort of
multi-way computation where
equivalencing things together and saying
that's the answer so to speak
okay so
what
what does this mean concretely so what
i've sort of been interested in
is
how
can we
where's a good example
how can we
uh you know what's the right model of
computation
in our environment
for something like this
and so again you know in our traditional
way of doing things
we're just doing um
you know we're effectively doing a nest
list of replace
um
blah blah blah or actually ultimately
we're doing a fixed point of replace of
blah blah blah okay what we're saying
here
is that what we want to be doing is
something like a nest list
of a replace uh list which in other
words we're doing all possible
replacements and then what happens but
what i think the most general a fairly
general thing is to imagine that we have
a list of expressions
and that we're doing let's say
you know f of a
g of b
f c
g of d
f c let's say g of c whatever else
and that what we're doing is something
more like a subset replace
on these which takes some set of these
things let's say g of blank comma
uh
g of blank
let's say g of x blank g of y blank
i don't know what it might do
um
and uh you know that might turn into the
splice let's say
of
um
uh let's say f of x
uh g of x plus y let's say
right and this so that would
oh my gosh that's what i get for having
some random thing defined in this
session um
okay so there we go so okay but but so
this is so the concept is
i mean this is kind of a
these things here are we're thinking
about they're like expressions or they
could be thought of as like tokens
and then there are these events
which are the rewriting
um
rules
that update to another
to something else and the point is that
that
in doing this kind of computation we
have to trace a lot more than we do in
ordinary computation it matters how you
get to a particular state
and
you know we have a bunch of use cases
okay where does where do we need to um
uh let's see
um
i think i had a thing here just see
sorry
um yeah
um
okay so what i'm trying to understand is
what what you know
okay let's imagine that we wanted to
take our theorem proving system
and
think about it in these terms
clearly there's a more efficient given
that we're only trying to find one path
there's more efficient things we can do
than to tree out all these possibilities
um
but you know so so among the things that
we're thinking about is you know how to
represent
a path
an evaluation path
um
you know
what to do with its um
uh what to do with its tentacles so to
speak and white by tentacles i mean
we're doing um
for example in in um find equational
proof which is after all doing something
very similar to this
i don't know if this is all making sense
maybe um
you know so so i mean find equational
proof might have
um
you know would eventually have a proof
graph that looks like this let's say
and that proof graph
is
something very similar to what i'm
looking at over here does that make
sense to people
um
although typically in this proof
what we've got is
you know
two expressions are coming in one
expression is coming out
and the uh the event
is the application of some kind of
substitution process that uses a lemma
inside a theorem for example
that makes sense
um
you know this is this is one example of
sort of this this model of computation
where you've got uh expressions and
events and so on
um
the uh
um
um
and the whole
this um and so
so that's that kind of case in in the
case of chemistry
we've got at the level of a chemical
reaction network we've got the same kind
of thing we've got chemicals coming in
we've got some reaction event and we've
got chemicals coming out you might also
think about that at a lower level in
terms of individual molecules but you
could think about that at the kind of
overall reaction level now one thing to
say is that that given this kind of
setup where you have these whatever they
are tokens or expressions you can
imagine
um
okay so this particular thing is a
single path of history this is this is
this is like the replace version this is
a replace list version
um which
uh
and then a thing we can do is we can
imagine de-duplicating this so that
there's only one instance
of every um
uh
you know every every token occurs only
once
and and then that's that's something
more like a petri net
um
and uh
i'm not sure that that's uh you know we
could ex we could imagine
okay
in our evaluator we really don't care
whether things occur all we care about
is did it reach a fixed point we
ultimately care about does it just cycle
i mean
in in our evaluator obviously we have
things like the x equals x plus one case
where
where
we won't get a fixed point and we have
in all these years we've never really
found a need to represent the evaluation
chain that's going on here it's just
like well it didn't terminate but we
don't have you know there's not a um
um
uh
you know we're not representing that
evaluation chain we're just saying it
didn't terminate
so
i mean i think uh
okay so that's the basic setup and i
guess that the um
um
um
that's a question a live stream already
about universal clocks no the whole idea
of these systems is there is no
universal clock and the whole idea is
that you're defining reference frames
that in the case of the interpretation
of physics you're defining reference
frames that tell you what events should
be considered simultaneous and so on
okay was this was this at least a rough
introduction was this i mean
what what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to figure out
what are the core functions is this a
general enough concept here to just have
these kind of collections of expressions
i don't think it quite is so okay so
here's an issue in
in a picture like this where you're just
saying replace
these things where you have these tokens
are interacting in this event producing
other tokens
that is not a particularly good match
with something like a string multi-way
system so for example here
we might have
uh somewhere here
we might have a string multi-way system
so what's going on here this is saying a
goes to bbb bb goes to a
the problem is that the token that is bb
is not that token is mixed up in inside
this expression that we've got here
and in the case of our hypographs and
physics
what's happening is that we represent
the we we are knitting together certain
tokens to say those tokens correspond to
a state
and the tokens are the things that get
to be consumed in an event
but those tokens get knitted together to
constitute a state and so in a sense
we've got several levels of knitting
things together we've got knitting
together tokens to make a state and we
potentially got knitting together states
to make some kind of reference frame
type thing where we're saying you know
across all these possible paths this is
these are the ones that we consider will
happen so i mean another issue is what
you know as we start thinking about this
kind of more fragmented lower level
version of computation how do we knit
together um
you know
how do we knit together things into
states or how do we take states and
break them apart to do um you know to to
be consumed in events
and one place where we've looked at this
we've got a design for this
which i consider to be a little bit over
complicated
is in
is in the multi-way system function in
the function repository um so if i look
at that
um this is
um
okay so here's multi-way system
and it has a ridiculous number of
possible
things that it looks at here
and you know just to give some
indication i mean there are there are
these states graphs which are things
like this
this doesn't really have a token i don't
think this is a token version does it no
it doesn't have a token version
um this has a causal graph version where
the causal graph is giving the causal
relationships between
different updating events it's saying
you know which event
the input to which event has to exist
for that event
how
yeah what is the relationship such that
one event is causally dependent on
another if the input to the
to the first event
requires output from the second event
and then we can draw the graph that is
the causal graph that represents these
things
and okay so that's that's the basis to
what extent are those actually distinct
or are those i mean because i see like i
mean a lot of them are things like all
events branch shilograph and all events
branchillograph structure which i assume
just means it doesn't have vertex labels
or something like that yeah exactly is
the actual number of base graphs you
know aside from these sort of
options is it like four or five or is it
actually like 50
no it's it's
it is
okay so let's enumerate them but i think
it it plays a little differently when
you've already tokenized things
this is at the states level
one is the state's graph you know the
the what states map to what states
then there's the bipartite so to speak
annotated states plus events graph
then
uh the other sort of then there's the
pure causal graph
which is
take uh let's see i guess you can derive
it
no no you have to say separately from
this you have to say what is the causal
dependence of one event on another in
these graphs
in the case of the token event graphs
those things are bundled together but in
this case you have to separately decide
what that causal dependence is
then the only other
well a qualitatively different kind of
graph is a branchial graph which is a
graph
from a foliation of this graph where
you're slicing across and you're asking
what are the ancestral relationships
between states in that case so i think
those are the main things and i mean
this
this has a lot of extra hair because
it's asking for things like
it's it's doing a lot of stuff about
effectively confluence checking and
causal and variance checking where it's
saying you know is and that's another
important point
is
i mean you know so
again well let me let me just bring up
one other thing here
um so just as an example of kind of how
this evaluation process works
in a more complicated case in the case
of let me give you an example where our
evaluator fails okay and that's
combinators so the issue with
combinators is
first of all
sometimes combinators well here let's
find a multi-way graph for combinators
let me just find it
um
okay so reminder you know combinators
are these rewrite rules for expressions
right
um and you have a complicated expression
and there are often many places where
the expression can be rewritten
um this is that this is that expression
and these
dark red squares represent sub trees
that can be rewritten according to the
combinator rules
um and the whole point is that one ends
up getting this multi-way graph of
possible rewrites
and
then what can happen is with combinators
is if with combinators have this this
confluence property that if it's going
to terminate
then you always get the same result so
even though there are many different
paths which we cannot parameterize you
know in our
evaluation scheme
we are you know if we just use slash dot
to apply the transformation rules for
combinators
we're going to go down a particular path
here
and
we don't have any good way to
parameterize what the evaluation order
basically is
and in general
okay i'm going to say but
in
if it's in the case of combinators they
have this confluence church russell
property that if it's going to terminate
it will always terminate in the same
thing it doesn't necessarily have to
terminate and we can find examples here
that's probably an example where an
example i don't know this is probably an
example
where some paths terminate but many
paths do not terminate
and we have no way to parametrize that
and we have no way and that's you know
this could we could imagine
that this combinator thing it could be a
search problem it could be you know
we're trying to fill out a tiling we're
trying to fill out a game tree these
kinds of things and there might be a
terminating case and there might be
non-terminated cases and we don't have a
good way to parameterize which of those
cases we're going to follow which is to
say
conceptually we can make the whole
multi-way graph
and then we could say we can slice it
down and that's a that's well i don't
know that's really the kind of thing
these these properties are doing but
that's that's the kind of thing we can
imagine doing now
in just to give a sense here in the
theory
in the case of combinators where we're
basically doing transformation rules on
expressions there are certain
conventional
orderings that we can use that are these
kinds of things that these are basically
part numbers in the tree and we're
asking in what order which which part
number do we replace first
okay
and so that's a and that could be
thought of as you know in this multi-way
graph that's effectively defining one of
the possible ways we can observe a
multi-way graph
is by picking a path
and one way we can pick a path is by
defining it in terms of what
transformations should occur
if that made sense
um
and uh to give a sense here
um yeah i mean so this is something
where in the way of thinking about
things in terms of multi-way graphs
where we've got
states
this is these are ways in which we're
taking states apart
where is it um how does that work let's
see i thought we had a thing
well these are state rendering functions
but i thought we had a way
to
define oh i guess it's in the internal
code how we take the um
how we take a state or an event apart
into effectively
tokens so you know
max has a somewhat cleaner
uh well i don't like his his
the the i mean he has code that is
dealing with these pure token event
graphs
um
and uh
um
wherever i had that so this is a token
event graph where again the states are
made up by knitting together certain
tokens they could be
and and
that that's and so
um
whereas you know in one view of things
so in the case of combinators
the knitting together of tokens is a
pretty complicated matter
because what you've got is not you know
even in a string you've got you know one
part of the string which may overlap
with another part of the string and
those both may be thought of as tokens
i'm not quite sure how to think about
that in a combinator it's much worse
because it's a tree structure and these
quotes tokens are all interwoven because
they're sub trees of each other i don't
know did anybody like max do you have a
comment on on how to think about tokens
from strings
well that means a three characters
so one kind of simple way to think about
them is you can emulate
string system with multi-set system
in a pretty straightforward way because
you just
have labels for so
characters are tokens they have labels
for different characters
and then you
join the neighboring ones
right once you represent it as a as a
multi-substitution system you can do
tokens talking about graphs
uh
like in a normal way right but then what
you're doing is you're saying
there is a character it's an a
and it's a position you know n
and it is oh you don't say it's a
position then you're saying there is
this character on the left and this kind
of okay fine it's a linked list it's a
linked list with ids basically joining
the characters
so okay so
to ask other people so first question is
can are there
analogies people can think of
and i mean
essentially what what i would like us to
be able to do let's take logic
programming as an example right
can somebody say
what would be the kind of
you know
well let's let's imagine that you're
you're trying to i don't know do
tic-tac-toe or something
and you're asking the question you know
is there a winning strategy for
tic-tac-toe
or you're trying to do the eight queens
problem which seems to be a very
favorite one um
you know in our language what would we
want to be able to specify and how would
we want to be able to specify you know
get to the answer for this
anybody want to comment on that maybe
you could say color maybe you could say
something about what you've thought
about with respect to logic programming
in the past
okay first i wanted to say something
that
um about
about the
strategy in which you uh form path and i
think that
you know in some cases if it's
probabilistic then basically you're
doing monte carlo sampling of this space
and yes and think of i think there's a
nice connection to probabilistic
programming here there is
yeah
uh with respect to uh logic programming
uh in general uh
you can define goals
so
what you want to do is like you're
trying to find a so you if in a sense
it's a lot like you're improving you say
uh i want to have i want to see if this
expression is a theorem in the system
and
often what you want to do is say
um
this is
this is a thing i know to be true show
me or i want to check whether it's true
or not and these are the actions of my
system and the actions might be
um
uh joe is
peter's father and father
is
and peter is
jack's father and you want to know who's
a grandparent or who
so sometimes it's filled with language
with all possible things and sometimes
you just give give a complete statement
so
jack is the grandson of i don't remember
the names i said but
anyone know whether it's true or false
it's rather once you want to list all
the grandchildren for example
right i mean so one model of that is
something like this find replace path
function that i had written a version of
um
so find replace path
is basically
rather than generating the full
multi-way graph and then just seeing is
there you know because you could
generate the multi-way path and then say
find path
or you can say
this is a sort of dynamic thing where
you've given a bunch of replacement
rules you know arob crod or whatever and
then you're asked is there a path from x
to y
and if so either show you know just
either your question is there a path
or
show me the path
does that make sense i mean is that that
that's
that's sort of a basic logic
yeah but programming more interesting
sometimes y has a blanket
and you want to know all the possible
things
that are
there that can be that blank
and in a sense there is a nice
connection here to uh rough databases
because that's what they're doing you're
filling blanks and you're trying to
build a graph
uh that that that can lead to those and
then list all possible solutions all
right let's talk let's ask tony then
what um you know how does this resonate
with our
sort of sparkle query stuff
um
good question i'm not sure if i can
immediately answer
because that's again a case where what
you're doing a very common thing in the
sparkle query case is
um find an intermediate on a on a path
right so in other words you're saying
um
what's a good example hey how do i get
up the documentation for
like think about an org chart of a of a
person
other company you can ask for all the
persons were directly or indirectly
managed by someone that would be a spark
a sparkle query that you can write
as complicated in sql
yeah and so
yeah
right so this is so
what you're doing
let's see sparkle select
i would think would be the type of thing
so in an rdf triple store
an rdf triple store
is defining a bunch of
um
what is what is the triple in the
trouble store because it's basically a
labeled graph so with our recent uh from
language release we got a third argument
in 2d
directed and undirected edges and that's
basically a way to represent those
triples in rdf stores
i see so the rdf so an rdf triple and
that's by the way
is something which is like
a a tagged edge
yes yeah but in case they act as tokens
because you can
when you have a triple you can also ask
what is the relation that links these
two things
so for example you have
stanley kubrick and shining and the
answer is director that's that's also
something you can do her matching on
okay so look there's a question of
relation versus events what we're
calling events here i think
are i mean so i would claim that in a
triple store that what you have
is something of the form um
you know basically x arrow relator
roy
or relation or whatever you call it
that that effectively that's what it's
like one of these graphs
maybe i'm not sure
yes it's it's like one the you can think
of the triple store as being like if if
the if the events are relations
this is what the triple store isn't that
right
this this is like a triple store
i'm not sure i would say that you know a
triple is
it's not even i mean
in a triple store you're doing all the
possible transformation like these are
the tokens
i think
so when you when you're
when you're exploring the thing and
getting all the possible answers you're
usually doing a deaf first search or
something like that
and then you get a table out
well is it wrong if i were to draw a
triple store
if i were to make a picture of a triple
store would it look like this
it's a state
it's it's essentially a hyper graph
yeah but what i'm saying is that what
when you perf queries
are the transformations on the triple
store
so in the in the sense of our multi
uh multi
computing thing you can say okay just do
a that first search and return the first
result or do an extensive search and
return all the results but those are
those are the transfer like those are
the steps of the evaluation right i see
so what max is saying is the
a triple store
is a hypograph
in which with with ternary hyper edges
is that correct
right
um i mean i don't see relation needs to
be any different from x and y it's just
another object yes fair enough okay so
it's just
so no no it's not because it allows for
reflection that way
what do you mean
like
usually statements where relation is in
the position of x or y
are basically the scheme of the of the
database so they're telling you what
relations are so it's a form of
reflection
say that again so so you're you're
what i'm saying is that you can say
something about
director in that you want x to be a
person and why
to be um
why to be a
movie
and and that thing is a statement about
the the relationship so there could be a
schema
yeah that's the schema our statements
where relations appears as x and y
okay
yeah but if you don't focus on just the
sparkle standards itself what stops us
from storing relations as objects of you
know type relation
in the same place
so that schema is part of the
database
yeah schema is part of the database
no i mean the only reason it's usually
different from the rest is like
it's permissions it's the fact that you
want to change the classes that's way
detailed i mean so
okay so now let's talk about um
a query
on this
you're claiming that the state of the
triple store is a hyper graph
and
but the query is something outside of
the triple store right you you give a
result it's not transforming the triple
store
is that true
some queries do transform a triple store
if you're updating or inserting data or
deleting
okay but so
okay but that's a rather trivial thing
that's not something where we've got
transformations
of the kind that we're thinking about
here
i mean that's different okay but but
answering well why wouldn't we couldn't
we in principle make a query that would
you know for free any group of
triples make another triple
we could but it's not what you usually
do i mean in terms of this the
difference between find replace path and
finding an answer from a sparkle query
in a if i'm not mistaken
finding an answer in a sparkle query is
a pure find path operation that is
the the you know the triple store is
sitting right there and all the query
does is to try and find a path in the
triple store is that a fair statement
yeah usually more than one
a pass or a sub graph
what when does it find a subgraph
for instance you can
request uh for all persons their birth
state and birth place
[Music]
i see i see
okay all right so that may not be so
directly relevant okay let's let's
turn maybe we can turn to a different
thing which is okay two things that have
come up recently we've got proof
representations and we've got chemical
reactions
which are both so let's let's talk about
um
proof representation
now
you know what does it look like when you
are
um you know we've got our proof object
thing
and our proof object
is um
where's a good example here
um
oh here let's pick up a random proof
object
um
so
this proof object
right now we have certain properties of
this proof object
um so we we can say
uh let's say the proof graph that's a
summary of the proof object so again
i view that i think if i'm not mistaken
this is very similar
i mean these are
each of those are axioms
two axioms
i guess we're not showing the laws of
inference here right two axioms derive
that lemma
and in this case
that lemma that axiom derived this other
lemma
how can that be why are there two
concerned does somebody know why why are
there two outputs from that substitution
llama there
is that just but i see it's just because
it happens to be used in
i'm a little confused by this maybe one
there's a causal edge
yeah i think it is i think that's what
it has to be
so there's a difference between normal
lemons and critical parliaments
which are triangles
the others are the seconds
right obtained in slightly different
ways
okay but this is showing
in some combination of the states you
know of of token event and some
combination of causal graph here
but you know again we can drill into
this and we can say
um
you know proof data set and now we've
got some representation
of
you know what is this doing this is
saying
this is saying
um
we've got
uh
let's see we've got this lemma
and then the proof what the heck is
going on here
right the proof is
so this is information of how we got to
this dilemma from previous lemmas or
axioms
right but effectively what it's doing is
it's defining
and in the thing that i had above the
simplified thing that i had above here
it is basically this type of operation
it's saying what actually happened what
did we what how do we instantiate that
law of inference is that correct
yes for a simpler
inference of the sequels the normal
lemmas
the the critical parallels are a bit
more complicated because you have to
unify
the two previous statements etc
right but fundamentally we are you know
the proof
shows
how we instantiate
um
instantiate
laws of inference
so roger you you had a um is roger with
us
maybe roger is not with us is roger with
us
no apparently not
okay
um
well we probably can't represent him we
just we're looking at
proofs
um
other situations in which we have proofs
i mean okay let's let's look at simplify
okay
so
simplify
um
you know
um
of potential proofs
so simplify as an example
right so simplify
does something very much like all these
multi-way graphs et cetera et cetera et
cetera
um
the uh
what
um
you know right now simplify we just give
the answer
we don't give the path how should we
think about giving the path
the path or the graph
um well the graph is we're not really
constructing the whole graph i mean just
like in theorem proving the full
multi-way graph we're absolutely not
constructing
right the full multi-wave graph is quite
complicated i mean you know for example
i made some recently
um
see if i can show you
uh
let's see
the um
let's let me just show you uh
oh actually i'm just um
um you know i i had done
okay these are
these are for boolean algebra
so that
is
these are possible transformations
for an expression in boolean algebra
right
and
every one of these arrows
these are equivalent expressions
but the question of what
uh you know proving a particular
expression
is
forgotten what this one is but this is
proving a particular expression is just
finding a path
through this graph of all possible
transformations all possible
equivalences
that makes sense
did that make sense
are you you were saying so that's one so
that that's the kind of proof where
you're
you have a path between equivalent
expressions whereas the proof in find
equational proof in general is not a
path it's a graph where you're combining
together
limits
um
look the only difference is
in one case is a sort of forward
multi-way graph
and the other case is this two goes to
one
let's say you're using modus ponens or
something you've got two expressions
and they are combined by modus ponens to
give one expression
but that's i mean that's the detail
i mean i think we're mixing up like the
proof graph
like that's only about how you tokenize
and and and put back together things
otherwise it's like operating on the
whole state
i'm not sure i understand
so
this is sort of quintessential example
of the thing that ian was mentioning
this is a proof
based on here are a bunch of
equivalences apply those equivalences
this is like a this is like one path in
a string you write system that's one
type of way of presenting a proof
the other type of way of presenting a
proof is where you say
is more like what find equation or proof
does where you're saying feed in a bunch
of uh theorems
and
your goal is to derive true from those
theorems
or or alternatively to start from true
and derive a particular theorem
yeah but what i was saying is that the
let's say this is
applying functions repeatedly the arity
of the function doesn't really matter
here when you construct a graph
so or here with strings the fact that
the pieces you pick have to be
contiguous it's still only a detail of
the tokenization
yes but it may be very important for the
language design i mean it may be
incomprehensible what's going on without
that
what i'm saying is that when you look at
the whole graph they should all look the
same like just an arrow it doesn't
matter then you took two parts from
different places that's the universe
you're you're modifying every time
you're modifying the global state okay
but no but that might be that might be
very
you know inefficient though i mean if i
understand what you're saying i mean you
could also say this for the um you'll
find equational proof where it's like
well you never
you you never need to use two separate
pieces of information and combine them
together i'm not talking about
implementation
christopher i'm not talking about
implementation i'm talking about the way
you think about like the way you
represent the graph all these things if
you want to unify theory has to does
shouldn't matter on the arity of the
function or on the tokenization i agree
i agree so i think that's tokens to
events that's the tokens and events to
other tokens
okay the issue is this we have we have
the notion of tokens we have the notion
that we have tokens we have states we
have events
we have reference frames
and arguably we have goals
okay
tokens are consumed in events
states are knittings together of tokens
i don't know whether there's an
analogous kind of thing for events
generally we have thought about events
as being just one-shot things
i suppose that the knitting together of
events is partly a reference frames kind
of thing
in the global
events take states as input and output
whether in local ones they take tokens
so sorry third again
so in the local multiverse system events
operate on tokens in a global
multi-system they operate on states so
the events themselves are different
well
more information in them in the global
multiverse system which means for
example for one event in the local
multiverse system there might be
multiple events that correspond to that
in a global one
yes but
look
in a global multi-way system that is
where you are operating on states so a
state might be a complete string right
you have to have information about where
did the event bite into the string and
so on
whereas
in
a
local multi-way system or a token event
type setup all you need to know
is you take this piece of a linked list
actually just these
yeah it is in fact a piece of a linked
list because it has the the wherewithal
to insist that it's that they're
contiguous elements
and then you're replacing it by
something
i i don't quite understand in terms of
the generality of this i don't
understand how for example combinators
and
nested tree-like objects work in that
respect
anybody understand that in terms of the
but i mean this is to me well this is
our propagation events and it works
similarly
okay
but so the problem is like if you think
in terms of implementation
you cannot just change a sub-expression
without also affecting the super
expression
so if there is data modification
necessary then it cannot be just one
event
okay so strings require linked lists
are effectively linked lists expressions
have
require essentially back filling events
so here's a way to think about it in
order to do a
in in order to change a sub expression
it requires you know of log n operations
and that's why it cannot be a single
event
if you find another representation of
expression which doesn't require that
then you know we could represent with
one event
so why does it require of log n because
you have to backfill everything because
it changes super expressions too
i see to re-net the results into the
super expression
so that isn't happening in the case of
in the case of linked lists you could
have another event that reconnects the
the tokens back into the linked list
but we don't happen to need that
well you could imagine those are not
expressions
no i understand that but you could you
could have a order one event
that is simply it takes it replaces the
tokens by other tokens and then it has
to reconnect the replace tokens back
into the original string
i kind of suspect there are cases in
biology where that actually happens
i mean you can even
construct the system such that it
constructs states
you know
as part of the
updating
and then of course when you change the
string you have to construct the new
states which would look kind of similar
to expressions
but it's not necessary for strings
right
okay so let's take another example here
let's let's talk about chemical
reactions
okay
can the people who've been working on
chemical reactions say something about
what we're i mean how does this you know
what is a chemical reaction
it's some kind of transformation on a
graph that represents a chemical
in effect that's what it is or or two
graphs that get combined uh
to form one or more new graphs and
uh depending on the complexity of the
total system of all the molecules you're
considering
and the events the reactions on them you
can form a multi-way graph over that
right and you can think of doing a
multi-way computation
that basically traces out different
paths in that graph
okay so the
are are full chemical graphs
and but the tokens are probably
something related to bonds or something
is that right i mean when you they you
could think of it that way that the
tokens are bought are bonds that get
moved around among a
collection a static collection of atoms
so that you're not creating or
annihilating any mass
that's the way i like to think about it
and the the events
or the transformations are just
rearranging the bonds according to the
rules of of uh chemical valence
but so in a typical
uh
let's say i'm you know to just pull up
some random website a list of name
reactions can you pick a favorite name
reaction here
should we do that uh
in delay whatever the heck
i don't know that one it's been a few
years since i've been in the lab but um
yes yes that's a good one there
okay so now let's just understand
what on earth is this this is okay so
it's taking
for a four atom molecule on the left
that has double bonds at the beginning
in the end
and a two atom molecule on the right
that is a double bond and it's forming a
ring out of them
a six-membered ring
uh
where the two new bonds that are used to
make the ring come from two of the
double bonds
uh in the original structure and the
third double bond actually migrates
all right so one thing they haven't done
here is put labels on this so in a sense
they're doing
they've
you know they should have labeled these
things right
yes
computationally yes for a computational
problem yes
okay sorry so again you were i was just
going to say that
a lot of information in chemistry gets
delighted and here the notation allows
you to align the c's at each of the
vertexes in that graph that's underneath
your cursor
i see but but why how would i know that
this thing didn't sort of flip itself
over when i got to here is that just a
convention of the way these graphs are
drawn and so on
more or less the diagram in the middle
of the page on the right shows the
the
the mechanisms
mechanism of the reaction as it's as we
understand it
and you can go from the left to the
middle to the right
and see that uh you know
the the atoms have not been rearranged
at all
it's just that the just the bonds are
moving
okay
and
this type of reaction is is very often
used where the individual parts are in
much larger molecules
not just the simple butadiene and
ethylene example here
and those uh extra pieces of the
molecules that in effect form a labeling
on the six atoms that are involved in
the reaction
and those those would move along with
the the atoms to which they're attached
yeah here's some examples here
but this is another horrifying thing
because this is stereochemistry where
where this is
beyond graft rewriting is that a true
statement
uh yes you have to take into account 3d
geometry if you uh
yeah
and there are two different ways this
type of reaction could go whether it's
catalyzed by light or by heat
yeah okay okay great okay now we're
we're descending into
into the minutia yes well you asked a
chemist
i understand
okay but so
but from our conceptual point of view in
the end a path
in a theorem you know the theorem
proving path the theorem proof is going
to look very much like this is like a
proof something like this is there a
first statement i mean this is the
sequence of steps yes it could be a
a part of a proof yes where the proof
would go from the very beginning of the
reaction scheme
all the way to the end over a multi-step
reaction right and where jose was saying
we do unification
um isn't that what is the analog of that
in chemistry the unification operation
go ahead the
that i'm not sure of i haven't thought
about that um the unification would be
something like a for all or there exists
well no it's it's a question of you've
got two pattern expressions and you want
to know how does one pattern expression
well i guess one version of it is how
does a pattern expression read on
another pattern expression is that a
fair way to characterize it jose
um i think so yes it's it's
fundamentally comparing different
patterns yes
right but but so so one of the issues is
you know
uh
tokens
could contain patterns maybe
in which case then then one has to do
pattern unification
to d to apply an event to a token
um okay what are some other examples i
mean another one
um you know for example we
let's take the case of of game graphs
um
what
in that case one one is just saying here
are the moves i mean
you know that that's that's here are the
moves of the game and can you get from
here to there
although in in the case of games
you might want something more like the
branchial graph where you're asking you
know this is a possible state of the
game what how do you score different you
know different configurations of the
game
um what about okay what about the the
tiling problem that max was looking at a
tiling problem
um
and can you say how that can be thought
of as a multi-way graph
how would you do it
you mean like the sliding puzzle type of
problem tiling problem
well that's a
that's i mean i used to think of it in
that way in the very beginning that it's
i think it's pretty far because it's not
a process
it's more of a sat problem
no but but you can think of it as a
process you're adding tiles well you can
think about the solution of an sat
problem as a process
sure because i mean any algorithm you
can think of no i know that but i mean
okay so let's take another example pure
recursion
okay so like fibonacci recursion
you are
the difference between a recursion you
know evaluating fibonacci
um
you know
is you're you're collecting all the
leaves
you want to collect all the leaves
which i claim is not really that
different
than a search problem you know a search
the analog of that a search analog would
be you you you want to pick a single
leaf
do you agree with that
i mean in in one case
it's really the same type of thing
you're computing
in the case of fibonacci you can think
of yourself as computing a multi-way
graph where essentially what you've got
is nest graph
let's see what what it is i mean it's
basically nest graph x goes to
if x oops i don't have the wrong thing
there um if
if x is less than
two then one
else
no then just a singleton one right else
x minus one x minus 2 if i'm not
mistaken and i want that starting at
let's say 6
for 10 steps let's say
am i going to get something crazy okay
so i claim
okay this is kind of interesting this is
a token deduplicated version of the
fibonacci
right of a fibonacci evaluation
yeah that's that's a
token graph and it doesn't show events
there are events take one input and one
output
i put the token event graph is a
generalization of this
okay so ian put a version of this with
tree
is this going to be the und duplicated
version
yes
sorry say what were you saying max so
this just i mean it's obviously token
graph not talking vent graph because it
doesn't show events
right but as in that it's just
like a talking event graph where events
have one input and one output
okay
no what i don't understand oh yes i see
what you're saying i see what you're
saying so this this will be two events
here
going from
five to four and three those are two
different events right
yeah
yeah which makes it a kind of a global
multi-system essentially
right although we could get a more local
version of this if instead of looking at
a scalar fibonacci with single integers
we were to look at lists here
um
okay
so okay so this is now the full tree and
what we're saying is
this is one way of exploring the
multi-way system so this is a way
in which
how do we think about this i mean the
token deduplication
is kind of like an observer type thing
you're making equivalence classes of
things
oh boy i don't know quite how to think
about that
now i i was going to bring up one other
example um actually this is a
christopher example let's see if i can
find it
navigating somebody else's
uh
look at this let's see if i can bring
this up
this is um
this is a christopher example of a
puzzle right this was looking the
duplication here
in something yes it is
yeah
so christopher can you say this is an
example right this is a
a sliding block puzzle which has certain
moves
sure yeah
and the object that you get
i believe
would we could call a multi-weight graph
yes probably although i'm not sure
exactly
which uh
well yeah i mean i don't know exactly
which which of the five different types
of graphs i think it's a state scale i
think you've got a state's graph i think
you're going from one state to the
sliding block puzzle to another yes yes
the um
and so
so in in your case here the question of
solving the puzzle is the question of
finding a path from the initial
condition to the final to a final
condition
yes
although also maybe note now this is
probably true for a lot of these
different situations i mean
the the rules are kind of complicated i
mean there's sort of a function that
will determine you know what steps can
you take but it's it's
it's like there isn't a simple symbolic
way of representing uh sort of the
if you understand what i mean there's a
program that's required to determine
what
what possible moves you can make
right but isn't it the case i mean okay
so let's say puzzle
solving and and and here
what what you're effectively saying is
um it is still just a state
transformation isn't it i mean given a
state
right and solving the puzzle is just
finding a path in that graph yeah
right
but there is a there is in in the
multi-way graph i mean you could you
could i know whether you're actually
using nest graph but you probably could
be
you're literally just saying
given this state there are certain other
states you can get to from that state
yeah although i'm not using nest graph
because it has the thing where it
doesn't assume that the functions are
deterministic but yes
oh that's another thing we needed to
talk about right
oh gosh that's right nest graph did did
we solve that does somebody know did we
solve that problem of assuming
deterministic functions in nest graph
or maybe to explain because that's a bit
of a cryptic way to put it i mean
basically that the issue is that if um
suppose that the function you give to
nest graph is deterministic nest graph
will still run it
you know several times so for example if
you if you do the the kind of trivial
web crawler right where the function's
kind of just like a
url section and get a bunch of urls um
then the point is if you hit the same if
the same website comes up twice it'll
call url fetch on it again
um which i can only assume is because
you know it it doesn't want to assume
that url fetch or i guess now url read
or something like that is
is uh you know deterministic um but in
the vast majority of cases it probably
is deterministic so there should at
least be an option that handles that
case because otherwise you know the
performance kind of spirals out of
control
and how does that relate to token
deduplication
isn't that the token deduplication
problem
i think it's the same as token
deduplication
can anybody comment on that
max or anybody
well i think it's similar yeah
but
a new point about talking duplication so
in the way you're doing it it's not just
memorization because it if
they duplicated talking when graphs are
not only
kind of conflated original token even
graph they
also contain events
which have tokens as inputs which would
not which would never appear in a single
state
so basically they tell you everything
that can happen even if it doesn't
happen for this specific initial
condition and you need to do that
because if you want to then use the
duplicate token event graph to run the
system from a different initial
condition
you should be able to do that
but we're just saying it operates at the
level of tokens there's no guarantee
that any given state will solve
everything
right but any given state i mean so this
was a picture here
of sort of petrinet style propagation
of what petri nets would call tokens but
we have to call markers because we
already have another thing called tokens
this this represents a state
with markers in that position
and this represents the propagation of
those markers to
successive states right right this is a
particular point is
in the
set replace chain i mean in the token
event graphs to duplicate one set that
branch in circle generates
you
can run this process starting from any
group of tokens not necessarily the
initial state and it will still work
yes i understand i understand this is a
complete summary of everything that can
happen yeah so it's a super regardless
of whether whether it actually happened
right so the so deduplication the point
you're making is deduplication
is
deduplication
uh
memoizes
everything
whether or not it was actually whether
whether or not or is the equivalent of
memory memorizing everything
whether or not that thing actually
occurred
right whether or not that particular
whether or not
it shouldn't really be calling or
pre-caching it's really a pre-caching of
everything
whether or not the thing occurs it's
expanding the rules into explicit you
know system
that you can
run in the you know the same way for any
system
so basically they're running a system
it's not a two-step process you first
generated the duplicated token event
graph also known as pedrinet
and then you run that pattern that in an
ordinary way like you would like the
same way for any system
right
okay but so so let's see
um
okay so
again pulling out to what we're trying
to get to here
the issue is what we want to do
is have
a sufficiently general formalism that
all these different things we're talking
about
you know chemical reactions proofs
etc etc etc
just like okay big picture
we've had a fantastically successful
general framework with symbolic
expressions and transformations from
symbolic expressions and an evaluator
that goes to fixed points and things for
lots of kinds of computation
what we would like to do is to expand
that to new kinds of computation by
having another general framework that is
like our evaluator but isn't our
evaluator
and
is you know so the question is what is
that what does it contain
right what do we and the most minimal
thing
would be
you know i don't think it's enough to
just say it's a big bag of tokens
because those tokens are knitted
together into states
and those states are knitted together
into foliations
and i i'm trying to understand how do we
represent those things
and then
when we run it
we might have something which is a i
mean what we thought about previously
was if i pull up some of the previous
stuff that we've thought about and i
don't remember maybe
um by the way we didn't even we didn't
even talk about probabilistic
programming here yet which is again a
very very similar kind of issue i think
did you agree i mean to people
um
uh
okay let me let me just see we had made
some notes previously about this maybe
maybe somebody
um
tokens are needed in the states through
atoms you don't need any extra
information to create states from tokens
acceptable you need to know how they're
related to each other
if we do it with atoms if if the tokens
are knitted through atoms but it's not
obvious to me that that's the general
approach
right so are
our tokens
always knitted
interstates
through atoms okay let me explain for
people who don't know the physics lingo
let me explain what that well atoms is
in a sense that answers to atom pew so
it doesn't have to be a quartus in the
character graphics the function names in
the previous example are all sources
okay but i'm not sure let's take i mean
somewhat ironically in chemistry it
might actually be atoms or it might not
be but i mean the basic point is the
tokens are the things on which the
rewrites occur
okay and the question is
are those tokens how do we know
how those tokens relate to each other so
in the case of hypergraphs
we're
you know just like okay how do we know
if we say f of x
and we say f of y and so on we know that
those two things are related because the
f's are the same
yeah so f is an atom in this case it
connects them
right but i mean in in um
okay i'm i'm not convinced that this is
a general general enough
i mean in other words tokens in the case
of chemistry we agreed up to
stereochemistry and other weird things
are basically collections of bonds
and it's not obvious to me that they get
knitted
together into compounds
maybe they do maybe it is actual atoms
in that case labeled actual atoms
that's that's possible um well i mean if
the same i mean sure i mean if it's the
same atom
then yeah
um i mean you can say in in cases like
strings
you don't have like when you just write
stream like in the usual way you don't
have atoms in it
but you need to put atoms so basically
in the case of strings the atoms would
be
labels for string positions
right i mean we have an example to
connect the string together
is it just just to be concrete here i
believe that the the um
the stringing
let's see i think there was an example
here
um
so this is
right
that is a straight and over complicated
one because it turns into character
graphs
not just multi-set systems
okay but this is
so what are you saying so in this i see
because it's got it's it's decorating
it's it's representing the a's and b's
using
uh
by by having a self loop for a b and a
ternary edge for it or not non-self loop
for an a
but basically the point is this is an a1
b2 et cetera et cetera et cetera in
other words it's got an index here
or more particularly i mean that index
is an arbitrary thing but that's just
that's the knitting of
tokens into a state basically i mean
it's not really an index because it's
not going to stay correct no i
understand
it's just an id
yeah it's just an id that is it is it is
an atom it's an atom label
that um
so that's the way that that gets knitted
and then the token
you know then if we say there's a
there's a rule that says bb goes to
whatever it's just statelessly looking i
just want a b and a b and i've got these
arbitrary things that are the the
connectors here which i then am going to
you know then the transformation might
turn this into an a
with those two connectors and those two
connectors necessarily connect back in
here
is that a good way can we think of
chemical reactions the same way
is this just like a chemical reaction is
this just like the application of a name
reaction
chemistry it might be i have to think
about a little more detail i was looking
thinking more at the atom level um
and there
you don't necessarily preserve the
number of hairs as it were
um
how can you not preserve it
how does it knit back in uh well i mean
that's what i'm i was trying to think
about is you know examples that
might be counter examples to having the
same number of connections
because i believe that that like in the
people thinking about chemistry in terms
of graphs you know double push out
rewriting and so on is the same
kind of um
story
maybe we can just ask a couple of other
um
let's let's pick on xerxes and or james
and ask about the category theory
version of all of this
can you comment on the relation to
category theory
if any
oh he's
saying something great but without audio
um
okay
um
all right i see that roger joined so
we've been roger i don't know i assume
you you understood what we're talking
about here
the
yeah
um roughly
i i would like to know other cases i
mean so we want to represent proofs
algebraic type proofs
are there other examples like for
example in the world of system modeler
are there examples of things that are
essentially this type of problem
actually here's a question in
system modeler has two-way
relationships between
things like a lever pushes onto this and
and the thing that it pushes on pushes
back on the lever and things but as i
recall there's a there's a version of
block diagrams that is more
well can you explain
how does any of this stuff relate to you
know system modeling
well there are two things
there is uh
there is at
at the high level which is discrete like
yours
um
there is something called state graph
stategraph is essentially a version of
petronets an industrial version of
petronets
um that allows you to have asynchronous
um you know updating and it's useful
for modeling things like chemical
reactions where reactions takes place in
parallel
you know and then until some event
happened you can't move on to the next
event things like that
okay those events
can be triggered you know so you um
usually you have event triggers since
you talk about petrinets
um
event triggers those in in the case of
system modeler those events can couple
directly to differential equations and
continuous reactions if you like or
continuous kinds of systems underneath
um so you can imagine those petronas
used to describe like a recipe you know
for a chemical factory
you know
heat these two
you know these
uh you know teaspoons heat the the fluid
in these two things then mix them then
um okay so you'll see the pressure then
you know do do a bunch of things but it
goes on in parallel the world is
parallel right right right but you know
the real point you're making so i mean
we i think we understand the concept of
these state graphs and um i mean we
might even we would actually call them
state graphs bizarrely enough exact same
name basically okay
state graph is a delica standard and and
as you get this is basically still like
an industrial version of what petronets
is trying you know which is sort of more
an academic version of things
um i wonder whether the state graphs are
exactly what we call multi-way state
graphs i think they might be i don't
know
but the thing you're saying is that
you're hanging off those you're hanging
differential equations yeah because what
those are typically used to model is
sort of macro level behavior let's say
that you have a drone
and you want to sort of model go from
this waypoint to this other waypoint do
this flip do you know and then do this
and other things that's a very discreet
set of things and actions to do
right yeah but underlying that you're
going to control the different fan jets
that actually you know um drive that
drone those are continuous control loops
those are con differential equations
and the same thing
happens in many kinds of industrial
you know kinds of systems like a robot
that moves around right okay but
basically what that means in in our
setting is our events what we're saying
is just a single event you're saying
let's break that down into something
which has a continuous
you know where you continuously go from
one state to another
yeah often that's that's i'm just saying
that sort of that's kind of practice
that you think of
you know kind of two or several levels
of systems
you know like you can model systems at
different tabular resolution now let's
drop down
to the the sort of
more continuous level of system modeler
you know system model is designed to
model
um you know basically things
engineering systems and most engineering
is related to
physics right because
um
you know electrical engineering
mechanical engineering
uh thermal engineering and whatnot it
relies on
that we have physical models you know
like like continuous
types of models now system modeler uses
um
differential algebraic equations it does
not it can use differential equations
but differential equations are very
limiting
so it uses
it uses differential algebraic equations
because then you can for instance just
put all these equations together and
then say this is what i want to find out
you eliminate what needs to be
eliminated i don't want to manually do
that as you have to do with differential
equations
the other thing that it uses to add
richness to the world that can be
modeled with those
and so so one one advantage of the die
which is called a causal modeling in
this space as opposed to causal modeling
is that they're not directed so you can
think of systems
like think of a
think of a battery electrical vehicle
there you have electrical motors driving
propulsing the car forward but when you
brake
you're doing the other way around
you use the electrical motors as
generators so you effectively run the
system backwards
okay but look in terms of our for
example you're saying eliminating
variables i bet that's basically the
same as token deduplication
yeah i mean the way we actually do the
elimination of variables is is is you
know a lot of it is structural
it uses big uh graph um graph reduction
schemes to know structurally what can
and should be eliminated trivially so
wait wait wait wait so you're basically
saying your differential equations you
represent the the system of equations as
a
graph yeah the structure of them right
and so probably a causal modeling is
probably an undirected graph and causal
modeling is a directed graph no
not so no
not how come
um
no it's just dependence it models
dependence what the triangular
dependence in some sense in the causal
case or something like that sort of yes
yeah
but that allows us to deal with things
like hundreds of thousands of equations
you know whereas if you actually have to
deal with the formulas for hundreds of
thousands of equations you can't
i mean you can't really simply okay so
one thing that you're highlighting here
is you know in terms of methods for
dealing with these systems there are
theorem proving methods i mean in the
purely discrete case they're if they're
improving methods
you're saying there are algebraic
elimination type methods
that you can imagine using to deal with
these large
large kinds of systems yeah so system
modeler that what we call compilation of
system modeler is to transform this very
relational
a causal model
into something that becomes causal and
can actually be simulated can be sort of
you know run numerical simulators on
i understand but if you were to adjust
if those events were just discrete
events
could the formalism of system model
still be useful or is the formalism
solely associated with sort of
actually having equations for every
event
uh
no i mean this is sort of both okay so
what makes it sort of rich is that you
need both events and continues so the
the physical world sometimes generate
events so for instance when you press a
clutch
you disengage something it's like a
discontinuous event or whenever when you
when a ball bounces right yes when a
ball bounces yeah and there's a bunch of
these events happening kind of in the
you know in the real world
and so they have to come somehow
you know come back you know and so what
we
do it's not only dies there's also
what's called hybrid
dies that means that you have events and
differential equations so you can sort
of
um like we do in mathematica too you
know like nd so
version nine no i know i know i
understand when events
we're going to run our time here and i
really wanted to
are there other people here who say i've
got a system that is also related to
these kinds of things
and did xerxes manage to connect himself
or
okay do you have comments about the sort
of category theory
versions of the kinds of things we're
talking about
some of them
are known to be expressed in category
theory but uh maybe for the others it's
not clear what type of category theory
one would use i mean in in case of petri
nets there are a
bunch of petri nets and their
generalizations some of which are
expressed in different types of monoidal
categories
in our picture
one may think uh one may think of
using petri nets in terms of uh global
multi-systems with the addition
of having extra objects an extra set of
rules for the tokens as if there are two
two kinds of entities one is where their
states are on top of that their tokens
but i suppose in the local
local multi way system patronage would
be more natural to interpret
but in category theory roughly a
monoidal category is the equivalent
of our of of parallelism
in some sense
well i mean
being monoidal has to do
with the fact that you have a tensor
product and you can apply this
normally you apply this tensor product
to to let's say to merge states
but then
the the
the key feature in the definitional
momental category is that when you are
trying to merge states you should do it
in such a way that it is compatible
with the with the morphisms or the
events that would have led to those
states so for example you have two
events that lead to two states and now
you want to ask what is the what is the
event that would have led to the merger
of that state
so it should be some sort of composite
uh
some sort of composite of the function
itself a composite of the event itself
so there should be a consistency in the
way the tensor product works and the
level of the functions that are
generating the next state as well as at
the level of the states so monopoly
category just gives you some consistency
conditions to keep track that you're not
doing something inconsistent in the way
you're doing mergers
okay for us i think what's practical
about minority categories is that gives
a mathematical justification
for how state mergers would would take
place in a consistent way
but so this reminds me of
in in
with finite state machines when you do
asynchronous products or partially
synchronous products
that you do a tensor product yes of the
states
and then you have a process that sides
that sort of filters out
you know what are the allowed
transitions
is this like the wreath product business
where you're taking products and
machines
yes
but there's like a whole family of these
asynchronous synchronous products
right i've never understood this the
crohn rhodes decomposition theorem and
all this kind of thing
is that what this is related to uh no
that's a
crown rhodes is isn't that sort of a
decomposition sort of of
one input to the other type thing yeah
and it's usually in terms of
semi groups and simple groups
right okay
that's a different okay so are we i mean
like for example if i look at a paper
like this
for instance
is this
how is this related you know you've got
hypographs in here always a good i mean
sorry you've got multi-way graphs in
here right
we uh we mostly explain everything in
terms of just uh string substitution
systems but what the statements are
generic they don't have to restrict to
one particular multi way or whatsoever
you're of course the the main point of
this was to say that uh we can start um
looking at rules in a systematic way
instead of just having some initial set
of rules and just put them all together
and see what comes out there's a
systematic procedure for uh applying
rules in in a way that you can clearly
see when paths are generated when paths
between parts are generated when paths
between paths between paths are
generated and so on and that can
systematically be interpreted
in terms of higher category theories and
higher homotopies
so what you're saying here is that in in
our evaluation usually you know our our
current evaluation model is incredibly
impoverished we just have this one path
that is just you know getting to an
answer
you're saying for example the higher
higher category business
is
like homotopies between evaluation parts
like in the case of in the in the
combinator case for example we could
easily
pick
you know we could say and i don't know
what it means particularly that two
different evaluation sequences for
combinators
there is some homotopy between those two
different evaluation parts and there
might be an obstruction
to homotopic equivalence which might be
something interesting but but that's
that's again that's a richer version
of the evaluation process than we've
been dealing with so far
and right
all right right as as if there's a
combinator expression between one
combinator tree to another itself
right
yes but it's a but but you're talking
about the higher homa top the higher
um
you know categories have to do with
higher morphism so that well this is the
this is a you know is is between a from
one proof to another proof right proof
is not
a single combinator expression a proof
is a sequence of combinator expressions
and that's the thing we don't have a way
to represent right now and look in our
language i mean you know okay so a key
lack in our language um you know
language design i mean a key thing we
have expressions
um
you know we have expressions but we do
not have a way of representing
transformations between do not
have a way of representing the process
of transformation
is that is that a fair statement guys i
mean so in other words we we can say
like in in the proof
you know when we give that in a proof
object it's a big mess how we say where
a pattern applies
you know where does a pattern apply for
example
which is otherwise known as
uh aka
how does a state decompose into tokens
isn't that right
so in other words when we say
we are applying a rule like in in
in that to wherever it was up here
this is saying
you know where does it apply oh it's
whatever it is i don't even know where
it says
sub pattern i don't even know where it
says where it applies but it has to give
a part number
for
where this rule
applies to this thing if i'm not
mistaken
and that's a very yucky thing which i
don't think we have a good way to do
anybody want to comment on that
i have to go in a minute but i'll just
say that um
xerxes i don't know if you've looked
into this but there are these kind of
categories called tanakiyan categories
that delene and milne have studied which
are basically monoidal categories but
they include some additional structure
that makes them amenable to
you know
transformation representations
and so maybe we should discuss this at
some point because if we're interested
in monolithical categories but we have
this
transformation representation problem
this might be a
a lead
yeah yeah but but here uh i mean uh
these tanaki and categories and others
those are of course special cases of
categories that are built for these
operations that you're mentioning but
this uh this kind of uh
i don't this framework rather of this
higher category theory is a generic
framework that that encompasses that and
many other such examples
here i was just giving a generic example
of how higher categories
gives you the mathematical formalism to
capture uh abstract homotopies and those
were useful for us to build these um
these higher multi ways with higher
order rules
okay let's let's okay anybody else got
comments on any other analogies and then
i want to just look at a few things from
our live stream and unfortunately we
have to wrap up even though this is i
think i consider this rather interesting
um
any other comments from people about
other analogies we haven't talked about
um and so on
i noticed a reference from our live
stream from richard about stochastic
logic programming okay that's something
we should look up i have not
i guess stochastic logic programming is
the obvious kind of probabilistic
programming approach
to logic programming
um
and i you know i don't know how this all
relates i mean certainly in like
quantitative finance and other places
there are endless monte carlo
simulations of processes that presumably
are closely related to what we're
talking about here anybody want to
comment on that roger do you have any
comments on that
sorry could you say it again
saying that in things like quantitative
finance you are deriving you know one of
the outputs
okay
a um you know
okay possible outputs
right
possible outputs they're things like um
you know add up every leaf add up every
leaf
which is eg recursive function
evaluation
okay another thing is uh find a winning
path
that's search logic programming etc
um
etc another is
um
find a probability distribution
over paths
which i claim
uh
or something like that that's like monte
carlo and things like this right
and that's like unlike probabilistic
programming i guess
is that a correct statement
i think so yeah
i was thinking like um
there's something i saw used in
economics and and metabolism which
reminded me of what roger was talking
about which is called the fun neumann's
model
where you have a bunch of
you know
little factories that consume inputs and
and produce outputs and uh you basically
want to know like what things are
crucial that if you turn off some faucet
the whole system halts
what aren't because they can simply
synthesize otherwise
and so on
yeah that's interesting so that that's a
different case where you're saying
yeah i don't even understand i mean
again the whole point is at the bottom
of it is some giant multi-way graph we
are sampling different pieces of that
multi-way graph
and
i claim these different forms of
computation you know just like our
current model of computation is input
crunch crunch crunch output that's our
model of computation
i claim here there are multiple kinds of
ways that we have to probe essentially
the computation object that we're
getting out
um
okay there's a question there's a few
comments on our live stream there
complaints about our theorem which i
think are a little bit
i i think our our find equational proof
is a pretty strong theorem prover as as
equational theorem provers go
um
and uh it's a different thing to to do
proof assistance is different and i you
know okay that's another actually that's
another kind of thing is the proof
assistant output there's not really an
output but another thing will be a proof
assistant which is a a kind of a human
assisted
path finding in other words the
framework that we've got here should
also allow a proof assistant where you
are you know human assisted
doing the pathfinding in a human
assisted way
right
um
let's see richard is saying edges can
represent axiom a is used in deriving t
but also theorem t depends on axiom a
is actually improv on approval right
okay yes there
um
let's see
richard is commenting stereochemistry
can be supported when you have
conditional rewrite rules
depending on attributes
okay
i can believe that
um it's being what geometry or something
like that
well i assume that this is some
attributed but it isn't just the state
where you're where you're carrying
information other than just the state
that's what that's what you have to do
you have to carry some metadata that
isn't just the the local state in order
to say how that glues into the rest of
the molecule yeah at the very least it
would be an ordering
if not 3d geometry
right
richard is commenting on robinson's
unification algorithm
which i do not know and i'm going to
paste in what he wrote here because i
don't know it
um
uh somewhere here i talked about
unification uh i don't know where it was
it's a standard theorem proving
uh
you know algorithm
right but how does this i mean so okay
so this is
um
right right right right but this this is
something very much like a sort of law
of inference
type thing is it not
i think so i think that's a
a
that's what we're referring to
generically as laws of inference i think
um
let's see richard is commenting common
sub expression elimination
um
complete that seems like an interesting
comment but i don't fully understand it
um
okay rich is commenting when he
implemented 3d visualization of our
physics of a basic version of our
physics project just unify the rules
with the graphs and then apply deletion
and gluing operations
yes yes i agree i mean you can do graph
rewriting with deletion and gluing
um
and the double push out is the algebraic
version of that yes i agree
um
uh okay so richard is pointing us
richard has suggested a number of very
interesting people that we contact
before so i'm i take his suggestions
very seriously here suggesting a certain
stephen muggleton
um
symbolic form of machine learning
okay
um
oh that's interesting okay well i think
we just have to look this up
um
and dan is asking about the theorem
prover is there a hands-on tutorial i
hope there is i mean i think if you look
up find equational proof i think it has
fairly extensive uh discussion
all right i think um
oh gosh we we've we're i think i have to
go because i'm really late for something
here but um
um
um and roger's just sending over a state
oh they they pointed to the state graph
oh i see okay
that's very explicit i mean we've that's
literally very petri netish here yes
isn't it lovely that there's so much
unification that we can do
i don't know i think i think this is
pretty interesting i don't know what
other people think but i think this is a
you know i think we're at a moment where
if we do this right we can really unify
a huge number of things
um it's just the heart the more
unification the more difficult it is
um
but
you know and the problem is to not end i
think that the very simple thing you
know we have compound expression means
that expression one is sequentially
after
before
well why don't we have
concurrent
expression
doesn't give an explicit ordering yeah i
know so i was thinking about a thing
called multi which is exactly that yeah
it needs to be kind of easy to do you
know kind of like vertical vertical like
or
uh instead of semicolon
that isn't enough roger because the
difficulty is
the the real difficulty is the thing we
take for granted which is the evaluation
process we have to we have to represent
that symbolically yeah we have to yeah
so but i'm tired of hearing this you
know the evaluator can't do this can't
do that like what the [ __ ] rewrite it
you know we rewritten everything else in
the system let's fix this but that's not
the point though roger the point here is
that we need a different kind of
evaluator
right i mean
the question of whether the evaluator
can let's say that so it can't be
multi-threaded because of memory
management in the evaluator okay let's
fix it yeah right that's that's silly
but i'm that's not my point my point is
that that the difference we need to also
have the authoring
okay money also needs to if if
if the author has done
with sequential promise in the code
it's it's very hard to sort of excavate
parallelism
you know back in smp back in 1979 i used
to have an attribute for functions that
said whether their arguments could in
principle be evaluated
not sequentially
needless to say
while that was in principle tagged in
the code it was never implemented no but
i could see i mean instead of using
semicolon between statements i can use
you know
a vertical bar
or something i mean yes but but but
but that's not good enough
the problem is what what we're realizing
is and this is the whole story of you
know a lot of what's coming out in the
physics project and so on the actual
representation of the process of
evaluation is important
it's not good enough all these multi-way
graphs that we're drawing
which actually matter what those graphs
are those are representations of the
process of evaluation
which happens to be a trivial chain in
the case of our current evaluator but we
need a representation of that and that's
something which you know like like in
look in in mathematical proofs for
example
there are usually sort of laws of
inference which are the implicit thing
which you do not represent you just say
this and this and this follow from this
and this and you're not sort of i don't
know what i'm trying to say this in in
our system the evaluator is
just
it just does what it does you're not
representing the process by which it
does it i mean that's what i tried to do
with trace
long long ago not a success but i mean
trace was an attempt you know if we say
you know trace
of one plus one plus one for example
that was not very interesting but i mean
in um um
i know what a good example is one plus
two times
two plus three something like this okay
whatever this is attempting to show
evaluation chains it doesn't do a good
job
we've never succeeded in making that
work that's what but i'm saying now what
we have to do is symbolic symbolicize
the process of evaluation and i really
need to go because i'm super late for
something but this was very interesting
guys and um uh
i look forward to continuing it and if
people have we will get a mailing list
going internally for this
process and project
and um uh
yeah to be continued
um all right i have to run thanks and
thanks to comments for comments on the
on the live stream oh richard has
another interesting comment here all
right we have to read these separately
um
uh great okay
bye everyone
thanks